هذه أجزاء مهمة جدًا في Mission Control ،
أنت الآن متصل بالطيار وهذا
خطأ لأنني الآن مصاب
بالاكتئاب لأنك في
قصة الخيال العلمي لأنك تنظر إلى
الأشياء التي تدور فيها أدواتك وتعتقد
جيدًا أن هذا سحر حقًا  أفعل هذه
الأيام من الليل إذا كان المنزل الصغير هو
السماء. استيقظت طعامي ، وأعتقد
أنك تحتفظ بالكرى لتتمكن من رؤية
كل جزء من وسائل النقل الوافرة
لعبور المحيط الأطلسي والآن وللمرة الأولى
هي الشمس-  طائرة تعمل بالطاقة ،
يرجى التكنولوجيا اليوم في تحقيق
أهداف موثوقة والطيران الآن لفترة أطول
بدون وقود مقارنة بالطائرة النقية
وستطير بقوة الطبيعة ستطير
مع الشمس ، إنه العصر الجديد
الآن للطاقة وهذا حقًا ما
نحب أن  إلهام الناس للقيام به